BERIC DONDARRION:
Death is the enemy.
BERIC:
The first enemy and the last.
The enemy always wins.
And we still need to fight him.
ARYA STARK:
You're scared, aren't you?
What are you scared of?
Hey, everybody episode 6 trailer
Let's break this down
And if you're finding me for the first time be sure to subscribe to get everything we only have a couple
episodes left in the season
There will be a couple of announcements about what's going on during the off season
And how we're going to handle book stuff next year because there's potentially two game of thrones
"Song of ice and Fire" books that will be released next year
But the whole idea of this trailer is that it's sort of like their return to doing a hardhome style episode
North of the wall, but because of the way the season is structured
We're still going to get scenes in other places like we have the stuff that's going on at dragonstone. We have the stuff
That's happening at Winterfell
so it's not all going to be set north of the wall even though that is the
Event of the episode like there's other stuff that's happening, but this right here. This is what's really going on
This is the thing that everybody's going to be talking about after the episode in a couple of you have
Already spotted a really weird cut that they have in here
So it looks like the Hound is using the exact same
Warhammer the Gendry is so people were a little confused by that last night like what's the deal?
Why do they have the same hammer so what I think is going on here?
Is that they just cut the trailer in a weird way in the Hound is just using Gendry's hammer?
And it's just from later in the episode so like Gendry
Maybe drops it while he's fighting the white walkers and the Hound picks it up
that doesn't necessarily mean the Gendry dies but I think the idea here is that
Beric is saying that death is the enemy the enemy always wins meaning that he expects to die
They'll probably be shedding a whole lot of their cast in this episode, so let's just do death predictions really quick
And I'll say right off the bat
I do think that they'll wind up killing Littlefinger this season
But I don't know if it's going to happen in episode 6 or if they'll push it to episode 7 because they have this
Sansa plot that they're hyping up
You don't see littlefinger in the trailer that much
But he's a big part of the episode
Because he planted that letter that Sansa was forced to write during season 1 about Ned Stark being completely out of his wits
Denouncing him as a traitor
So just remains to be seen how much they stretch that winterfell plot out because that's basically what's happening at Winterfell right now?
There's nothing else that's going on beyond Bran just trying to help them out north of the wall
So just open up a tab
Separately from littlefinger from all the stuff that's happening north of the wall so north of the wall death
Predictions magnificent seven this is going from my most likely to die to my least likely obviously
I think that Jon Snow is the least likely to die because he's so critical for the plot
So he's got that heavy plot armor protecting him, but starting with most likely to die Beric Dondarrion
Thoros of Myr, Tormund, Gendry, Jorah, the Hound and then obviously Jon Snow
And I know a lot of people are like where's Benjen. I feel like if he's going to come back
This is the episode to do it
He's also on that death
Predictions list but I don't want to talk about him too much because he's not really in the trailer
You just have to remember that the dead cannot pass Beyond the wall. That's what the enchantment
Does is it prevents people who are either half turned like benjin or people who are full white from crossing so they haven't really articulated?
On it yet, but Bran was marked by the night King
Supposedly that has something to do with him making it south of the wall it also
Enables him to sort of track Bran where he is so like he can see him at Winterfell in that sort of psychic
Weirwood Network space where they're looking at the past present and future
I Still want to know if they're going to have some sort of psychic battle before the end of season 8 but it sounds like that
Might not wind up happening this season, but I do feel like Bran has extra abilities that he just hasn't completely figured out yet
They do it on comic book-TV shows all the time where like the Super hero gets powers
But it takes him a couple seasons
To unlock all the crazy abilities that he has in the comics like all the abilities that he has all the knowledge is
Already there in his brain
It's just that he hasn't figured out how to make use of it in the way that the three-eyed Raven was so he just needs
More time to mess with that
But I know a lot of people will be super bummed if Gendry dies
As they want that Arya reunion
as much that would be total fanservice, I do feel like they brought Gendry back just for this moment here
This is a bit of fanservice to say hey
We didn't completely forget about this character. So early on when it seemed like he was coming back. I was like oh man
There's all these things they could use him for he's this Master Blacksmith
They could learn how to remake Valyrian Steel arm
Everyone that would be a great way to use the Gendry character even if he wasn't around for every single episode
But it kind of seems like they're not going in that direction
and because there's only six episodes in the final season it just remains to be seen so
Cross your fingers for Gendry
Escaping Arya is going to be so pissed with John if she finds out the Gendry went north of the wall
there are a couple references the things that happened earlier in the season too  so as they walk into the frozen North you see the
Hound double-take as he looks at the mountains. It seems like an arrowhead
That's what he saw in his vision
And then you have this big open area with the sort of platform of rocks in the middle
That's sort of the staging area where you see John and the others see the whites start to spill through that little opening there
is they start running for their lives to make it to that
we got our brief look at it earlier in the trailer so all these themes of Jon Snow and them standing here just from a
little bit later in the episode
There are only three of them on that rock so that does make me wonder if the others have died by the time they're standing there
But I think that's just because you can't see
behind them
So it's not so much a question of who's going to die its of how fast are they going to kill all these people?
Because I do think that more than half of the group guaranteed is going to die
But a very small chance that Jon Snow is the only person that survives because we do see this lone horse riding off
So I think that's Jon snow just barely escaping with his life, and that's probably Benjen's horse
So just remind everyone please do not post spoilers for the episode in the comments
Obviously, we're not going to be able to see it till next week once we get a little bit closer to the finale
We can start making predictions for season 8 some of you have already started to do that and they have
Already finished all of the scripts there are six episodes in season 8 the writing is all done the thing that they're doing now
before they actually start
shooting the episodes is
Just figuring out how they're going to accomplish that because they've kind of been referring it to six 2 hour movies
But that's not guaranteed
So we might get six movies for game of thrones season 8 which would be awesome considering that we would normally get 10 episodes
But we'll see how that goes we'll talk about that more after this season
We don't really see Cersei anywhere in this trailer
But there were so many people on my episode 5 video that are absolutely convinced that Cersei is lying about that
baby
So we'll see when the episode drops because they do sort of jump forward in time
Quite a bit and cersei doesn't look like she's anywhere near her second trimester like she's barely showing you can't tell with those heavier
That she has on, but I will say yes
I do think that she's completely irredeemable now that she's lost her children the whole idea. Is that she's completely unchained
It's totally possible that she's faking that baby
So that Jamie won't go anywhere, but I don't think that she's worried about that at this point
I think the whole reason for that baby on the TV show which does not exist in the book
She doesn't get pregnant again in the books is all about giving you the semblance of hope the Cersei will see reason
Agree to the Armistice see the white and then help out, so they'll lay down their arms
They'll all come together the way that they need to divide the army of the dead
Because the whole thing about Cersei is that her children were basically her soul
So when her children died her soul died too, so she's completely unchained now, so if she were to have another child
It's almost like she would get her soul back, and it would be something to redeem her
But if that baby were to die then she would just go off the rails which I do think that it well
I think it'll blow up in everyone's faces in Cersei will do something super terrible, and we'll finally get to see Jaime
Just go that's enough of this. I'm out of here. There's all that Jon Snow Targaryen Rhaegar annulment talk from last week's episode
There's so much stuff happening with what's going on north of the wall
I'm not expecting them to immediately follow up with the rhaegar bomb that Gilly dropped
maybe they'll say that for episode 7 there'll be at least one more scene to sort of touch on that and broaden the
Context like they wouldn't just leave you hanging with that
Until season 8 so what's going to happen next is I'll post my Q&A video
Just leave all the questions that you want me to include. There is a new round of that, HBO Now, giveaway
I'll just announce the winner when I post that Q&A video what's going to start happening in the off season
Is that they'll start spinning up westworld they're shooting
They're going to be premiering that probably in the spring next year in the books that George R Martin might be releasing next year
He just casually dropped that he might have two books to release next year is fire in blood the targaryen family
History book that he's been talking about for a long time. That's actually pretty cool
It's just like a history of song of ice and fire told from the perspective
Of the targaryen family and then obviously winds of winter
So he just casually saying that there might be two books instead of just winds of winter
So what will happen is if it takes them till?
2019 to get season eight out then most of my game of thrones bonus videos between show stuff will be booked videos next year
So you have plenty of time to catch up if you haven't started reading the books yet?
But while you wait for everything you can click here for my episode 5 video again?
And you can click here to learn all about the children's the forest and the white walkers symbols that Jon snow found
Thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight